- Straight up, for 90% of you,
this is the greatest year
of your life right now.
That's just the truth.
(upbeat rap music)
(upbeat music)
Just landed in L.A.
I'm going to talk with
the USC football team.
Just called Colin on the
team now to do some articles.
Hey Colin, how are you?
Super well, real quick, when
you say brand put your brand,
your product, your service, your business.
You know what I mean?
When you say document there,
you're gonna link that
word document to document and create?
- [Colin] Yes.
- Okay keep going.
Ah, what you say interesting like
a media company ad or end or a publisher.
Got it?
And brand is everything
if you're trying to create
a business of value.
Now in the modern digital
landscape instead of social.
That's how you make it.
One of the reasons I want
to write this article is,
I think people see that alfa anger
competitiveness, hunger.
You know how?
Go to fuckin Google, dick.
(audience laughter)
And they misunderstand that
it is under the context
and the guise of the business scheme
not overall life.
I don't even know if I want to
position it with that title.
I think it's more about
dissecting being misunderstood.
We need to make it more
of a macro-conversation
of everybody being misunderstood.
Like for me, this is less
about a piece of content
that I want out there for me to point to
and more of a piece of content to empower
people to keep doing their thing,
because a lot of them
are not doing their thing
because of other people's opinions.
For me, I'm empathetic to being
misunderstood not combative.
Hey Tony, it's Gary
Vaynerchuk, how are you?
Good how is your summer going so far?
So I want to talk to you
about the creative pillar
and the pros and cons of
where you want to take it
creatively and we'll have that
conversation right after this.
The part that you can count on me is
you will be able to go to Long Island city
to our podcast studio and that
is literally where you can,
we will set it up for you.
we will design the logo for you,
we will get you on the iTunes and Spotify,
all the Google platforms.
We'll give you the kind
of one on one of how
to get people to listen to it
and where you send people.
We'll do podcasts in a box for you.
All you will really need to do
is just come to the studio
and tell your guests
to come to the studio, record and leave.
(upbeat music)
What's the best and the
worst part of being a CEO?
Which is everything is on
you, the ups and the downs.
Let's use Anchor from afar,
we don't each other
that well but I followed
Anchor very closely from the beginning.
You came out the gate
and then there's that
two to three weeks when everybody
was on your nuts, right?
You were gonna be this thing
and it was exciting and it was
the first time you did this.
And you're like, oh man, what
the hell am I dealing with?
Gary V's talking about it,
all these people are talking
about it, VC's are coming at me.
Real people I looked up
to in tech care about me
are on the platform and then for everybody
who's listening, tell them what's happened
over the last 12 to 15 months.
You had that high and then they low comes
and you're trying to build the product
and the articles aren't
being written about it
and you actually have to operate
and you actually have to
build something successful.
There's a lot of
competition and there's the
other flavors of the week, right?
So like the loneliness of that is real.
I assume from afar, one
week you're like oh my God
I'm the next Instagram and then a week
later the market doesn't care.
And that's what entrepreneurs
have to deal with.
Everybody's excited when
they start their company.
What happens a month later?
The answer to my question is,
I try my damnedest.
I think about it everyday.
I obsess over my business every second.
I obsess over, am I doing
the right thing as a parent,
as a father, as a husband, as a brother,
as a son, as a human to society?
And you let the friction of that ambition
play out everyday and some days you win
and some days you lose
but you never give a fuck what anybody
thinks about your wins or loses.
And confidence goes in funny places.
We're doing this interview,
I would tell you,
listen, I love you and love
this platform so I'm doing it
but it's not the biggest
interview of my life, right?
And I gotta tell you,
your phone call comes in
and I know it's a hidden
number 'cause I've been
playing with your platform
so I knew it was you.
And it's so weird what
went through my mind
which is, I literally,
this just went through
my mind, I'm about to give the
best Anchor interview of all time.
Yeah, it's like one of my most
watched YouTube videos of all time.
But it was maybe the
entrepreneurial class.
Let's start with this.
I fully, 100,000 percent with no hedge,
do not believe that you
can teach entrepreneurship,
right, so that's awkward.
(crowd talking)
- [Woman] Already got a
(mumbles) guy for you Gary.
- How are you?
- I've never been happier.
(laughter)
- (mumbles) boosters.
- How's it going?
- [Man] Awesome.
- [Gary] Life is good?
- Oh, yeah.
- Good.
- Where you from originally?
- I was actually born in Russia.
- Okay.
- Beautiful facility, huh?
- Yeah.
- You know how to do it here.
(crowds talking)
(laughter)
But the reality is,
that's your reality right?
You know that that's the reality
but to your point, there's
nothing against collecting
business cards, it's
only about relationships.
You need to dap it up with
as many people as possible.
Life is only about the people.
I made tens of millions of dollars
because I became friendly...
I thought Twitter was gonna be important
and I made those relationships
with those founders and that's
what opened up everything.
Everybody you talk to
ever, ever that's made it,
that really made it,
it's just relationships.
I would meet every single
person, siphon and learn.
They want to see you 'cause
they want to take a selfie
and show their 14 year
old son they know you.
You want to see them
because you wanna win life.
- I think you have to have
a balance to it too though.
(upbeat music)
- For me it's gratitude.
I'm super grateful man.
I was born in a shit place.
Got out of Russia when
nobody was getting out.
Got lucky, I'm grateful.
If I wake up and everybody
in my family is alive,
I'm so fuckin fired up.
I don't watch shit, I
don't listen to shit.
I'm just like, I'm so grateful.
Yogi, like a fuck,
I just like, you know I
don't know what else to say.
I'm just super...
I'm part of this non-profit,
Pencils of Promise.
I took some of my people
and went to Ghana.
Went to Ghana, landed in Acra
and then drove four hours.
These were places people walk
an hour to get fresh water.
That man's water bottle there,
they would fuckin die for that shit.
I just think everybody's lost perspective.
And I'm real empathetic that
this room's lost perspective.
You're a football player of USC.
Your perspective is broke.
It just is, so I like try to unwind.
My perspective is I'm
a white man in America
and I'm rich as fuck.
My perspective is broke.
So I'm trying to rewind it
back to just be grateful.
I'm just grateful.
So the way I stay on the
edge and just like gratitude.
It's just gratitude, one life, one at bat.
One time, I just don't
want to see that regret
in my eyes that I see in so many.
And that's why it's so fun for me to come
and talk to you now
because straight up for 90% of you,
this is the greatest year
of your life, right now.
That's just the truth.
You can be made at me,
you can be sad at me.
You can think I'm stupid.
I'm telling you straight
to your fuckin faces.
For 80 to 90% of you, this is it.
This is the fuckin pinnacle, so you better
squeeze the fuck outta this thing.
Because if you're smart and
you do then it won't be.
- [Man] Yeah, I couldn't agree--
(laughter)
- It is 'cause it's true.
It's not like I'm smart,
I'm just looking at data.
- [Man] Well if you think about it.
- I'm just looking at history.
I'm just talking to people.
Just being a student of life, it's true.
What they're doing isn't right
because they're full of shit.
They're just not
delivering on the promise.
- When I talked to (mumbles),
I was asked all the same
questions, why did you get in?
What's your reason now?
And that's the difference.
- Right, my difference was, I bought it
'cause I'm gonna buy the Jets
and I just wanted to learn
for 30 years from now.
- Right.
- Now I'm in it to fuck it up.
I want, I'm being dead serious.
'Cause I want people to understand.
I want to tell you the truth.
I want in my Wikipedia to say and then
in the 2017, he entered
the sports agency world
and he fucked that up too.
Yeah we gotta go.
- Let's get a pic before
you get outta here
so I can send it to JP.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Yeah, can you get one for me?
- Appreciate it man.
- Y'all be easy, awesome pleasure.
- Such a pleasure man.
- Yes sir.
- I'll see ya.
- Appreciate it man, congrats
and blessing with everything else.
- Same for you, good health.
That was fun?
- It was great.
- Alright, we gotta go.
Can't wait, coin toss baby.
(crowd talking)
(upbeat music)
Alright, DRock, let's
see how this one works.
DRock said, do you have a rant in you?
I go no, then I said yeah.
- [DRock] I don't think
you said no, by the way.
- What did I say?
- [DRock] You said yeah.
- Oh I said yeah?
- [Camerman] You said yeah real fast.
- I said no in my head, that's wild.
This is a funny way to start this video.
Just spoke to the USC football team
and I said something in there
that really caught my attention.
(smack hands)
- [Gary] Alright where's this guy?
(laughter)
How are you?
- I'm good man, how are you?
- What's your name?
- My name is Marquet.
- Marquet, real pleasure man.
- Yeah, i was just watching your interview
with The Breakfast Club man.
- Thank you my man.
- Very motivational, I appreciate that.
- I recognize your face, I'm like whoa!
Let me say what's up to that guy.
- [Gary] (laughter) I
appreciate it, my man.
- Alright man, take care.
- [Gary] Have a good one.
What's that?
- [DRock] You want to walk home?
- [Gary] I can't.
- I'm John Rowe.
- John, real pleasure.
- Yeah, I coach here for a football team.
I played for a couple of years.
I fucked up my shoulder but now I coach.
- Make sure DRock you wanna talk
to this dude to get the right--
- So you still use Uber?
- Yeah, it's funny, I
couldn't find my driver
so I had to use it like,
was the perfect spot.
You know what's funny?
So what do you think, I just care--
- Cam Early, he's my roommate.
Cam, the guy (mumbles)
talked about wine in the--
- That dude is awesome.
- Yeah, he's my roommate,
he's my best friend.
- My favorite baseball player.
- I don't want to hold you up.
- Dude, if there's anything I could ever
be of help to anybody, let me know.
- It's all good.
- Take care.
How are you?
- [Driver] Good, how are you?
- [Gary] Good.
(upbeat music)